♪
♪ DON'T LET THE SOUND OF YOUR
OWN ♪♪
>> CRYPTO COMMENTS.
A LOT OF TIME TO TALK ABOUT ALL
OF THESE CUSTOMERS THAT YOU
RIPPED OFF.
FORMER FTX FOUNDER SITTING IN A
JAIL CELL AFTER GETTING DENIED
BAIL.
HE IS FIGHTING EXTRADITION TO
THE U.S. ON WIRED SECURITY FRAUD
CHARGES AND FACES UP TO ONE OR
15 YEARS IN PERSON.
THAT PLAYS OUT, WHAT ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS WHO TOOK HIS DIRTY
MONEY?
WILL THEY GIVE IT BACK?
REPUBLICANS, TOO, FOR THAT
MATTER?
BANKMAN-FRIED WAS THE DEMOCRATS'
SECOND-BIGGEST DONOR, NEXT TO
GEORGE SOROS.
THE WHITE HOUSE DOES NOT SEEM
INTERESTED IN TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> CAMPAIGN DONATIONS THAT MAY
HAVE COME FROM CUSTOMER MONEY.
>> I HAVE COVERED HERE BY THE
HATCH ACT.
ANYTHING THAT IS CONNECTED TO
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM HERE, I WOULD
HAVE TO REFER YOU TO THE DNC.
>> SOME DEMOCRATS ARE CALLING
FOR THE MONEY TO BE RETURNED.
>> DO YOU THINK THE SHOULD BE
READER RETURNED TO CUSTOMERS AND
INVESTORS AS OPPOSED TO DONATING
NOW THAT HE IS ACCUSED OF FRAUD?
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
I DON'T FAULT INDIVIDUALS WHO
DONATED THOSE FUNDS BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY HAD FULL
TRANSPARENCY AT THAT TIME.
>> DO YOU WANT TO SEE FELLOW
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS THAT
YOU DONATED TO ALL RETURN THOSE
DONATIONS OR DONATED THEM TO
CHARITIES LIKE WE HAVE SEEN SOME
DO?
>> YES.
I THINK THEY SHOULD RETURN IT TO
SHERIDAN.
>> LET'S SEE.
JUDGE, THIS GUY IS IN A LOT OF
TROUBLE.
HE SAID HE IS A VEGETARIAN AND
HE HAS A.D.D. AND THEY DID NOT
GO WITH THAT SURPRISINGLY.
SO HE STAYS IN JAIL.
YOUR REACTION TO RETURNING THE
MONEY?
SHOULD -- ARE THEY OBLIGATED TO
RETURN THE MONEY?
>> Jeanine: YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE POLITICIANS RETURN THE
MONEY.
FIRST OF ALL, IT IS GOING TO BE
VERY DIFFICULT.
I THINK THEY SHOULD RETURN THE
MONEY ABSOLUTELY.
THIS MONEY IS FRAUDULENT MONEY.
IT IS DIRTY MONEY.
AND IT WAS PART OF A SCHEME TO
DEFRAUD AND THE SCHEME THAT IS
BIGGER THAN ANYTHING I THINK WE
HAVE EVER SEEN IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO LET'S KNOCK IT EACH OTHER.
THE MONEY SHOULD BE RETURNED.
IT IS GOING TO BE COMPLICATED
BECAUSE A THEY ARE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A BANKRUPTCY, THEY ARE
STARTING THE BANKRUPTCY
PROCEEDING.
YOU HAVE BOTH STATE AND THE
FEDERAL LAWS THAT WILL
COMPLICATE AT THAT.
IT APPEARS THAT THERE ARE
1 MILLION CREDITORS, 1 MILLION
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN CONNED OUT
OF $1.8 BILLION.
SO IT IS GOING TO BE VERY HARD.
I MEAN, JUST THE LOGISTICS OF
THIS AND JUST GETTING ALL OF THE
FACTS TOGETHER IS GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT BUT I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT TO START BACK OKAY?
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT HE KNEW SOMETHING WAS
COMING UP.
AND THAT IS WHY HE STARTED
PUTTING SO MUCH MONEY INTO
NEWSPAPERS.
AND GIVING IT TO JOURNALIST.
BECAUSE HE WAS TRYING TO BUY
THEM OUT.
HE SAID, I JUST WANTED HONEST
MEDIA.
HONEST JOURNALISM AND HONEST
VOICE HIS.
YOU ARE BUYING FAVORITISM AND HE
HAS SOMETHING LIKE $300 MILLION
IN BRAZIL.
OKAY?
THAT HE PUT THERE IN AN EFFORT
LIKE MOST DEFENDANTS WHO ARE
WEALTHY IN AN EFFORT TO GET AWAY
IF HE CAN ABSCOND AND JUST USE
HIS MONEY TO CHANGE HIS IDENTITY
AND THAT IS WHAT ROBERT DURST
SAID.
THAT IS WHAT THAT IS WHAT SO
MONDAY DEFENDANTS IN CASES THAT
I HAD WILL DO.
SO FORGET THAT HE HAS THAT ADHD.
FORGET THAT HE IS A VEGAN.
I DON'T GIVE A DAMN.
MY CONCERN IS IN THE BAHAMAS,
YOU BETTER STAY THERE.
I WANT TO HEAR THAT HE TICKED
OFF THAT THEY CAN'T FIND HIM NOW
OR THAT HE KILLED HIMSELF AND
ALL OF THAT.
CLEARLY.
>> THE PRESS SECRETARY RIGHT THE
HATCH ACT PRESENT -- PREVENTS
HER FROM TALKING ABOUT THIS?
>> I FIND -- THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES CAN HAVE OPINIONS
ABOUT ANYTHING HE WANTS.
THE HATCH ACT VIOLATION IS WHAT
YOU DO.
YOU SAW THAT IN THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
THERE WAS A VIOLATION OF SELLING
T-SHIRTS AND YOU SAY, OKAY
SORRY.
THIS IS SOMETHING WORK AT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
COULD HAVE AN OPINION IF YOU
WANTED AND IF HE WERE TO EVER DO
AN INTERVIEW AND HE WOULD BE
ASKED ABOUT IT, HE CANNOT SAY, I
CAN TALK ABOUT THIS BECAUSE OF
THE HATCH ACT.
THAT WOULD NOT FLY.
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THERE
IS A WAY TO DODGE.
ANYTIME YOU CAN FIND THE SAFE
HARBOR, YOU SHOULD TAKE IT.
BUT THE PRESIDENT OF NINE STATES
COULD HAVE AN OPINION.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THESE PARENTS SEEM TO BE
THE ONESS WHO SEEM TO BE IN ON
IT.
I THINK THAT IS REALLY
DISGUSTING.
THERE ARE LIMITS ON WHAT YOU CAN
GIVE TO A POLITICIAN.
LET'S SAY IT IS $5,000.
SAM WAS SAYING, JESSE, I KNOW
YOU DON'T HAVE AN EXTRA FIVE
GRAND.
I KNOW YOU WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
ACCESS.
I WILL TELL YOU WHAT I'M GOING
TO DO.
I WILL PUT IT IN YOUR NAME.
SO YOU DON'T -- THE FACT THAT
WAS STOLEN MONEY.
SO NOW I'M CURIOUS ABOUT, WHO
ELSE, IF YOU KNEW ABOUT THAT,
THEN ARE YOU IN TROUBLE AS WELL
IF THAT WERE TO HAPPEN?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT ABOUT THE CELEBRITIES?
KEVIN O'LEARY, $50 MILLION TO BE
A SPOKESPERSON.
DO YOU THINK THEY SHOULD FEEL
COMPELLED TO GIVE THE MONEY
BACK?
>> THAT IS A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION BECAUSE IF SOMEONE CAME
TO ME AND I HAD NO IDEA THIS
THING WAS A SCAM, AND THEY WERE
GOING TO PAY ME, $50 MILLION, TO
DO A COMMERCIAL AND A TAD FTX, I
WOULD PROBABLY TAKE IT.
I WOULD PROBABLY TAKE IT.
>> WOULDN'T YOU DO A THOROUGH
VETTING?
>> OR YOU GIVE THAT MONEY BACK.
>> I WOULD LOOK AT THIS GUY'S
HAIR AND NOW HE WAS A SCAM
ARTIST.
BUT YOU KNOW, TOM BRADY AND
KEVIN O'LEARY, THEY ARE JUST NOT
AS PERCEPTIVE AS I AM.
>> YOU ARE MORE ATHLETIC.
>> JOHNNY WOULD HAVE SEEN THE
SKY SHAKE UNDER HIS WITHERING
QUESTIONING.
AND I LOVE SEEING SOFT RICH MEN
GO TO DIRTY PRISONS.
I LOVE IT.
I LIKE KNOWING HOW GRIMY THE
CELL IS.
THERE'S RATS.
THERE'S VERSIONS.
THERE'S MAGGOTS.
THE REASON YOU ARE NEVER GOING
TO GET ANYBODY TO ASK JOE BIDEN
IF HE IS GOING TO RETURN THE
CASH IS BECAUSE JOE BIDEN --
INTERVIEWS WITH DREW BARRYMORE.
HE HAD NOT DONE A REAL INTERVIEW
IN MONTHS AND THEN -- DO YOU
THINK DREW BARRYMORE IS GOING TO
ASK HIM ABOUT THE DIRTY MONEY?
OF COURSE NOT.
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
JESSICA, IN THE BIG PICTURE, I
THINK THE OTHER THING TO KEEP IN
MIND IS I THINK CRYPTO IS IN THE
DOCKET, TOO.
WARREN BUFFETT CAME OUT AND
SAID, THIS STUFF IS NOT REAL.
ALMOST ANYBODY IN THE PLANET.
I THINK WE HAVE TO RE-EXAMINE.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO FALL
LIKE A HOUSE OF CARDS.
>> Jessica: THAT SEEMS TO BE
WHAT WAS TRYING TO BE AVOIDED.
THE GOVERNMENT WAS FINALLY
LOOKING INTO IT AND WE ARE TO
COMBAT REGULATING AT.
MORE DEMOCRATS THAN REPUBLICANS
WHO THOUGHT THAT IS WHERE WE
NEEDED TO GO.
I REMEMBER THE TRANSITION WHEN I
WAS STILL LIVING IN LONDON.
WE ARE OPENING UP, WE ARE GOING
TO -- BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY.
WHERE GOING TO START FINDING OUT
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THE DARK
WEB.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS SO WEIRD.
THAT GOVERNMENTS MUST HATE THIS.
IT REMOVES ALL CONTROL FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO CHERISH CONTROL MORE
THAN ANYTHING.
BUT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
RETHINK THE IDEA THAT
"FREE-MARKET" IS REALLY THAT
FREE BECAUSE YOU END UP WITH
PEOPLE WHO DEFRAUD PEOPLE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
>> I WAS UNDER THE IMPRESSION,
THE POWERFUL KNOW SOMETHING WE
DON'T.
>> MAYBE NOT A SKINS CARE
ROUTINE.
>> I'M HEARING THEM TALK ABOUT
WORLD LEADERSHIP AND THE S